dr neil postman of new york university
why did you write the book amusing
ourselves to death
because
television
is an awesome
technology
that has the capability of completely
changing
the culture
so i addressed myself to television not
only in this book but
a couple of others i've done
i'm trying to explore
how television is changing
our culture in as many ways as i can
this particular book
deals mostly with
how television alters
our views toward
politics religion
news to some extent
education
so
i regard myself as a social critic of
sorts
whose job is to call to people's
attention
problematic issues that arise in the
culture and television certainly is one
do you watch television
i i love television
i think it's particularly good
in sports
i think that's a strong point
i i try never to watch television
when
uh it's serious because i always find
that an embarrassment
when people like
tom broke or
walter cronkite pretend that they're
doing something serious i'm always
embarrassed by that and prefer to watch
old movies and sports
why
why
uh why do i prefer that no why uh do you
think that tom brokaw and walter
cronkite are trying to are pretending to
do something serious well
i'm embarrassed by it
because uh
c-span
aside
the function of television in america
is to gather an audience
which can be sold to advertisers that's
its its fundamental purpose
um
it should be pointed out that
when radio first came on the scene
uh such conservative observers as
herbert hoover who was secretary of
commerce
when the
radio act was first
passed didn't
believe that it was possible that radio
could be used for commercial purposes he
saw it as strictly an educational medium
and probably would have been horrified
to see what has happened to radio and
television but by the time television
came along it was well established that
this would be used as an instrument for
the advancement of corporate profits so
what television is mostly in america
is an attempt to gather an audience for
any reason in other words in a way
television is quite unprecedented
in that in the past audiences were
gathered for specific reasons to hear
speeches or
even to see specific events but
television doesn't do that its job is to
gather an audience and it doesn't really
much care
what it uses as the means to gather an
audience now to get to the book
i discovered a couple of things that
american television knows that the best
way to
gather an audience is to provide
something that is amusing
and it may be
brian we could get into this that
television may not be good for for
anything else
i mean you'd probably want to quarrel
with me on that but
in so far as we're talking about
american commercial television that's
what it its
best is
to provide amusement in order to gather
an audience and so
um when cronkite or or broker try to do
something serious the the first thing we
know
is that within
eight minutes
they're going to stop for a united
airlines commercial
now the point is how serious
can it be whatever it is that they're
saying
if after eight minutes they're going to
stop for united airlines or calvin klein
jeans
i mean they could be and of course the
same thing as with our six o'clock and
eleven o'clock news how serious can a
flood in mexico b
or an earthquake in in japan if it is
preceded by a calvin klein's jeans
commercial and followed by a yogurt
commercial
i mean that fact in itself
so changes the content of what passes
for news that
i find it
an
embarrassment
to
to the very idea of an informed public
so that is that's one of the i mean even
when uh
whichever network did the uh show on the
holocaust
i mean thank god they didn't have a
commercial for uh the brooklyn union gas
company you know which is conceivable
and i think by the way once happened
when the play judgment in nuremberg
was done many years ago
but how can you do a drama about the
holocaust
with calvin klein jeans commercials in
there
that doesn't make it a drama about the
holocaust anymore that makes it into
something else now just beyond that
perfectly obvious that people like bro
core and rather are there
because they're attractive men
so that
what passes for newscasters in america
is something quite different from what
we used to know as journalists
i mean these are among the
most gorgeous people in america
and they're there because they're
charismatic and they're good looking and
they're they have memorable faces and we
know that people
largely watch the news
because of the news teller
not so much the news and in any case the
news would only be in 32nd
fragments so that
when television does news when
it tries to do what americans now call
political debates
this cannot be taken seriously
by
an informed public i mean what is a
debate
we have
president reagan and vice president
mondale
in front of the camera
and someone like barbara walter says
first question
for you mr president is what do you
think
is the solution to the problem in the
middle east you will have two minutes to
answer
after which vice president mondale
will have 60 seconds for rebuttal
now who can take that seriously
if reagan and mondale
were serious men in fact
they would turn to miss walters
and say what kind of men do you think we
are
we're running for the highest office in
the land
you can't answer a question like this in
two minutes
nor can you rebut someone else's answer
in 60 seconds or they might turn to miss
walters and say what kind of people do
you think the american public is
that they will put up
with a forum
in which candidates for the presidency
are asked to respond to a question like
this in two minutes and or one minute
but in fact none of that ever happens
reagan does answer
and mondale does give his rebuttal
and everyone goes on with this charade
that television is informing the public
in fact television i would argue is not
it's amusing the public and that this is
not a legitimate form of political
discourse but is taken right from
uh the values of show business
what's the effect of this if you're
right
well
there are lots of effects
one is
that
it may well be
that although the american public knows
of many things it knows about very
little
and may be maybe
the americans may be the most
ill-informed people in the western world
i did a survey
a couple of years ago of what people
knew about iran
and i chose the that subject because the
iranian hostage crisis
had recently been completed
which means that for every day for over
a year
the television news dealt with the
iranian hostage crisis so if there was
any subject
you could expect the americans to know
something about
it would be iran
and i asked several hundred people some
simple questions
one of them being where is iran
what religion do the iranians practice
where did the shah come from what does
ayatollah mean
questions of this sort i found out that
most people knew nothing those who did
when asked how do you know this
said well they read it in the new york
times or time magazine had done a story
about this and so on
now i i concede
that television is a is a window to the
world
as old television executives like to say
but it's it's a curious kind of window
with interesting distortions and
refractions it presents a fragmented
world
um i mean this would be typical wouldn't
it brian of
something happening
on the news say the voice over says or
the
newscaster as he's called says more
shooting in
beirut today
then we see some film of a street
perhaps in beirut
a body on the floor we hear shots
um
maybe see a woman leaning over the body
this image is powerful
so people know of
beirut they know there's shooting in
beirut
do they know who's shooting at whom
or why or what is the historical context
for this
television news doesn't speak to that
because it's it's a visual medium that's
one reason
language is not its strong point
it deals in fast moving images so the
first thing the
directors of new shows want to know is
do we have film footage
i mean uh uh how this uh help david
halbestein did an interesting piece in
tv guide about a year ago about the
growth of the japanese economy
that this story
had been building for years
but americans really didn't know about
it
mostly because there were no visuals to
show
so the television for all practical
purposes ignored it what could you show
well i guess you could show graphs but
tv directors don't like to show graphs
they like to show
more exotic and
interesting dynamic images so
in the first
place television
is interested mostly in gathering an
audience
and it does it by keeping people amused
in the second place it may even be
that television is not
a suitable medium
for the communication of serious ideas
after all
an idea
is sentences
language
and
television is not
terribly comfortable with language its
strong suit is the visual image
maybe in the end that's what
we should rely mostly on television for
and in fact i i suppose we do now
any is now this book was originally
written in 1985
published in hardback
uh this is now out in paperback i guess
can you get in most bookstores
i hope so
did anybody react to this book in the
first place strongly
negatively
get letters from people in the business
saying how dare you
no
because mo uh i mean that
there was at least one um
uh
quite
a hostile review in the blanetic
most of the reviews were pretty good
especially in the new york times
but
when i hear from television people
they're usually quite um
in agreement
because they
most people who are in television
know that what i'm talking about is
largely true
i mean they
they understand that when you do news on
television
what you have to do is do it in
30-second
bites
i was on a ted koppel program
and uh
i i should say i regard him
as
one of the few men
around
who does try to bring some intellectual
decorum to television
but he would be the first to concede
that in his 30-minute
nightline program
he has got to follow the show business
rules
which is for example you can't let
someone talk
the way i'm talking here
because
this
is just a talking head
and although
couples program is
more talky than others
he always tries to have two or three
guests if he can
so they can move to other people and he
doesn't want you talking too long and he
knows that every few minutes or whatever
it is maybe it's eight minutes for him
he's got to stop for a commercial
so there's going to be discontinuity
in the whole event
he struggles hard to overcome this sort
of thing
but but i'm quite sure that if he were
here
he would agree that this is one of the
problems of commercial television i know
that mcneil of mcneil era has written
things very similar to what i've
said in this book as a matter of fact he
got an award at new york university uh
which required him to give a speech in
which he said
pretty much the same thing
bill moyers has been very interested in
this book
and has also talked about these issues
so when you
think of the serious people who are
somehow trying to
master this medium
they understand that they
they're coming up against certain
obstacles that make it difficult to use
the medium
at least within the american context
for any other purpose
than just gathering an audience
it's not enough time to go through all
this book and if we did then people
wouldn't have a reason to go out and buy
it uh one chapter that just caught my
attention because it's something that
i've noticed over the years
uh it's chapter seven of the book and
later we can get a shot of it the the
chapter heading is now
this
explain what now this is all about well
i like to think that
television newscasters
have created a new
grammatical category
see now this is is a special kind of
conjunction
but whereas we were taught in school
that conjunctions connect
one thing with another
now this is a conjunction that
disconnects
one thing from another so that when a
newscaster says
and now
this
he means that what you're about to see
has no connection with what you have
just been seeing
and that you must not be morbidly
preoccupied with what you've just be
you've just been seeing and you must now
pay attention to a commercial
now i think this now this
phenomenon
is terrifically important from a
psychological point of view
for instance
what sort of person
is sitting at home
who
is addressed in the following way
the newscaster says there was an
earthquake in mexico city
we're going to show you pictures and a
hundred thousand people
are believed to be dead
goes on
now this
and now the calvin klein jeans
commercial is on
well now let's just think of what is
required
of the audience now
ought the audience to be saying now wait
a second
i i can't think about a calvin klein
jeans commercial
we're talking about a hundred thousand
people
buried possibly
let's get back to this
uh
well television doesn't want this
because if you linger too much
on this story from mexico city then you
can't pay attention to the commercial so
they've invented this
curious piece of language you see now
this
and that's a signal it says whatever
concerns you had
whatever feelings might have been evoked
by some of these dramatic images we've
shown you forget about it
because now we want you to pay attention
to this commercial
it's very strange does it make you mad
when you hear that well it it of course
it used to but of course one is used to
that
and by the way brian i've often thought
what would happen in a book
if this
for instance when you were reading this
book
if somewhere
along about page
six
i said
something like
now before i go on
i'd like to say a word on behalf of
chase manhattan bank
and then do a little promo for chase
manhattan
now the thing is what would happen is
you'd probably throw the book away i
mean you'd say well what in the hell is
this guy doing or
you'd say
what kind of fool does he take me for
if he wants to engage me in a serious
argument
then he has to have continuity
in tone and in content he can't expect a
serious reader
to read along for five pages
and then
shift gears
to to think about chase manhattan bank
or pan am airlines
you wouldn't accept this as a reader
and uh what how people have got
conditioned to accept this on television
is one of the great psychic
uh almost revolutions of the past couple
of decades
that people do not get angry
they've just incorporated it i mean
they've just
accepted that discontinuity is a feature
of this medium
and a television can tell me about
anything
no matter how serious
grotesque appalling
but i know that it will only go on
for about 40 seconds
and i also know i have to be prepared
to switch psychic gears
so that i forget about that
it's very interesting i mean i don't
pretend that i understand it all
myself but it's quite different
from
almost any other
medium i could think of i mean in a
movie people wouldn't stand for it
somehow
when you put a movie on television
however
people do accept it
i
last last time i was watching
inherit the wind
in the middle not in the middle of a
scene
but in the middle of a sentence by
spencer tracy they just cut it and went
to a commercial
and i was wondering well i i mean i know
these things are computerized and maybe
they just
have it figured out you know every six
minutes
uh they go to commercial
but i suppose they were thinking what
difference does it make if we cut it
here
or if we cut it at some other point the
audience is conditioned to this sort of
discontinuity so it's no problem
do you
have any
suspicion that the home video cassette
recorder
might eventually grab a hold of people
to the extent that it will really hurt
television in general because of this
very thing you're talking about you get
it in context
i read an interesting
quote by federico fellini the other day
where he he was talking about the remote
control the zapper
and he said that
just to begin there and he said that the
zapper makes
each viewer
his or her her own director and
exhibitor
and i have to think about that because
obviously that
changes the nature of the television
experience he also remarked
that it
creates a very
impatient audience
that
that the the the viewer holding the
zapper
has had his or her
um
what shall i call it tolerance span
uh re reduced i mean there was a time if
you had to get up from your seat
that you would give something a little
more time before you would change it now
you know you can do it in a few seconds
as as for the the video tape recorder of
course that's changing everything
and the better
or you think this is all bad is this all
bad that we're talking about here
i i i mean from civilization impact
those kind of things
i don't i don't really know i mean one
uh
it it's conceivable
that it could change everything for the
better
one the most interesting fact
that i know
in the history of
communications
is this
that
the printing press
was invented in germany about with
movable type uh in a roughly the year
1450
it wasn't until
the year 1516
almost 70 years later
that anyone thought of numbering the
pages in books now you think that that's
something they would have thought of
immediately but they didn't it took that
long before someone thought of it i
mention this because by numbering the
pages and books
obviously you change the function of
books you can use them in ways that you
can't use
unnumbered uh
books on page books
this video tape recorder may be a
comparable switch
that it
changes the structure of network
television
that
it may be
that
and here's where the better comes in
that since people would have available
all the entertainment stuff they want on
videotape
that eventually television will really
make an attempt
to become a serious form of public
communication i mean that's conceivable
it's conceivable let me ask you on that
note about you talk about
the difficulty of keeping an audience
why do you think
we may get more than we deserve out of
this question
why do you think somebody would sit here
and listen to you for a whole hour
it's astounding to me i don't think i
would
um
well
in the first place i mean there are
people
perhaps a declining number
who are interested in
language
in discourse in ideas
and that they will turn
a to language because they find that
stimulating
you see still a lot of this on european
television
where you will have talking heads
uh some of the most brilliant people
poets philosophers scientists
just
like this saying
wonderful words
and there are still audiences for for
this in europe
one hopes that there are audiences for
this in america that you'd know more
about this i'm hoping the same way you
were uh uh you know that we're in drugs
than i would
but
this is something both of us have to
worry about you from the standpoint of
your attempts to do something different
with television
mind from the standpoint of an of an
educator
we both have to ask ourselves
uh what uh what's happening with
language
jacques lul the
well-known french
sociologist recently published a book
with the title
the humiliation of the word
and he makes the point as others have
that
one of the characteristics of the new
media
television and vcr and even film
and
mass-produced photography and so on is
to humiliate the word that is the word
moves to the periphery of the culture
and the visual image takes its place
at the center
now that is happening
how fast it's happening
whether or not anything can be done to
slow the process down is another
question but i mean there are people
obviously i don't know if they'd listen
to this kind of talk but they'd listen
to talk if it's good talk
and if it stimulates their mind
but i don't know
if you could get a mass audi i mean i
write about in the book
uh on this whole question of a political
debate
i wanted to remind my fellow country men
and women
that if you look at the most famous
example of political debate in american
history
namely the lincoln-douglas debates
they should know that lincoln and
douglas had many debates
and throughout illinois
and some of their debates lasted for
seven hours
lincoln speaking for three douglas for
three
and then lincoln
an hour of rebuttal and then when they
moved to the next town the other way
around
can you imagine an american audience
listening to seven hours of talk
today
i doubt it and if you look at some of
the transcriptions of the lincoln
douglas debates it's it
it doesn't even seem possible to me
that an american audience today
could understand the language the syntax
is
fairly complex
the references are uh require a great
deal of now i mean it's my guess is
brian
that the
the electorate in america today
if it heard the gettysburg address for
the first time
would not be able to understand most of
it if for no other reason than that the
syntax is too complex
so uh one does worry about the fact
that language as a means of public
communication
has become
increasingly
less important if that shows my own
uh
disabilities and language but has has
diminished
in in its power
president reagan is perfect example here
is a man who is referred to
as the great communicator
yet he rarely
speaks accurately
and never precisely
yet he's called the great communicator
and probably with good reason
in in the 1860s he would have been
unthinkable
because he he he can't talk
you put him on television and he's
dynamite
because people
see
let's put it this way
talk about politics for a minute
politicians
there are two kinds of information
in political discourse
what
irving goffman used to call information
you give
and information you give off
now by information you give he means
words
reasons explanations
facts conclusions language
by information you give off he means all
the non-verbal
information
that
the image gives
now the ratio has been changed
prior to television
people
concentrated mostly on the information
the politicians gave
their language
after television they concentrate on the
information that politicians give off
so if bruce babbitt has pop eyes
or if
paul simon
looks like a mater d in a second class
restaurant
or if george bush
looks like more like an ex tiddlywinks
player than an ex-first baseman
this cuts very deep into the
consciousness of the public this is why
they all have image managers i mean bush
bush is a very interesting case because
everyone says you put him on television
and he looks like a wimp
now actually if there's anyone in this
campaign
who has better macho
credentials
than george bush i don't know who it
would be i mean i think he was the
youngest navy airline pilot
in world war ii
he was head of the cia
he's a first baseman on the yale
baseball team i mean
this guy should be like rambo
you put him on television and what he
gives off is altogether different
so he has to work on what not his
discourse not his ideas but somehow
giving off different things from what he
gives off
um let me ask you uh jump in and ask you
about the lincoln douglas debates how
many people actually sat there for seven
hours
well uh uh
almost everybody who went i mean these
are how many people have that were that
well used to attend they went all you
know that i think they started them the
the uh the seven debates that we always
call the lincoln douglas debates did in
last seven hours i think those were
three
uh although they the two of them debated
many times before that and there were uh
uh
several hundred people at each place
they went they went to i think they
started in ottawa illinois and then they
they went around and of course
rhetoric public
public debate
language
in the middle of the 19th century
was very much part of the social
uh life
and also the intellectual life of the
people i mean
they loved debate they loved rhetoric
and they got uh i mean going on the
stump as they called it was quite common
throughout america and of course writers
uh
ma even
mark twain especially
made small fortunes
giving talks
now i'm not i'm not pining for those
days
i just mentioned that
so that
one can get some sense
of what a medium like television does it
changes the ratio
of
of the communication
means okay let me stop there and ask you
about a little bit about yourself you
teach do you teach you actually have
students
sure real life real live students how
many mostly graduate students
although i ha i have recently been
teaching how have you talked
well i've been at nyu for uh 27 years
so you
and that's 27 years of television
and there's been television around
during those 27 years
have you noticed a change in your
students over the 27 years absolutely
and i would say most um
most teachers have been around this long
will give you the same give us the same
well uh
one of the things that worries
all of us of course is writing skills
and um
here's an interesting thing about this
one of the fundamental
ideas
in language
and in reasoning
is that you must try to avoid a
contradiction
all reasonable people
are suspicious of contradiction and
keenly alert to contradictions in
people's discourse
now
i've discovered
that sensitivity to contradiction
in the writing of my students has eroded
i'll give you an example and i i
mentioned one in the book
this would be typical saying to a
student now look john
in the first paragraph you say
such and such is true
but in this third paragraph you say the
opposite is true
now
that's a contradiction
which is going to be
and john says no problem i say yes
problem he says no problem because
i said this is true here
and now i say this is true here.
now i don't know how to explain to such
a student what the problem is
if a student does not really have a
well-developed concept of what a
contradiction is very hard to explain it
and i've talked about this to many
teachers
and they've said yes they've noticed
this
uh especially the writing of their
students and we've speculated on why
this could be
and i think i have an answer although i
may be wrong on this
see writing is a very linear process
that's very sort of logical you know you
go down the list
television and film as well
have different structures i mean you can
look
there's a picture
it's on for 30 seconds and here's
another picture
and then here's a third picture and
here's a fourth picture
there is a kind of
there is no logical structure
to the images that you see in the media
and this may have something to do with
this erosion
of a notion of of contradiction
print people
like myself for example
people who make their living with words
are very sensitive to contradiction and
have trained ourselves to ferret out
contradiction
and when someone is speaking to us we
can almost see the words
on the page and we say things like let's
go back
to what you said two or three sentences
ago
that seems to contradict what you say
when you say let's go back it's almost
as if you're looking at the page well
the kids born
just 25 years ago i don't think have
this kind of sensitivity to language
or
notions about it so
that's
one thing that i've noticed and many
others have noticed what about an
interest i mean as television
uh had an impact on what their interests
are
you've got the book uh the cultural
literacy uh what i was thinking of
bloom's book yeah well cultural literacy
is even a better example the i don't
know if you know that book
by e.d hirsch jr
uh it's usually paired with alan bloom's
book but
he's the
guy who
hersh is who had an appendix
in the back of his book of
oh i don't know 1500
names
places events aphorisms that he thought
the
an educated person should know
and uh
and many people have been appalled at
how little
the youngsters know about
these things
and in a way it is it is terrifying
to have to to to make a reference
to
hitler
or churchill
or even
roosevelt and see
kind of look on the student's face
faces that says you better tell us who
these people
are
i mean there is something terrifying
about this but to enlarge the scope of
this discussion
i'm not blaming the youngsters for this
we do have a
what might be called an information
crisis
especially in america because
we're the only culture in the world that
really is
living with 20
20th century technology and this is the
crisis
up until very recently in human history
people suffered from a scarcity of
information
and one of the functions of school
was to provide them
with
solid reliable important information
that
the the students could not get outside
the classroom walls
now we have for the first time
the opposite problem
not information scarcity but information
satiation
if you look at hersch's list of what he
thinks the average american should know
he's got babe ruth
but he doesn't have hank aaron
he's got austin texas
but he doesn't have trenton new jersey
he's got the beatles but i don't think
he's got rogers and hammerstein
so you look at the list and say well
this is almost completely almost
completely arbitrary i could make up a
list of another 1500 things
that he doesn't have why these 1500
things
so
the point is this the kids know
thousands of things
that
that i don't know
and i know thousands of things that they
don't know
now what should i do
well i can make them know the things
that i know
but somehow that doesn't seem to me the
answer
because
there are still thousands of other
things that i that they should know
about that i don't know and you see the
problem
and of course the computer technology
just compounds this
we have a situation where people are
dying
not from lack of information
but from too much information because
they don't they've got this new problem
of what information is relevant for them
to know let me ask you about politics
because that's really what this network
is devoted to
you've got a chapter reach out and elect
someone
you wrote that in 1985 and you also have
a chapter right before that called
shuffle off to bethlehem which seems to
recognize
the televangelists long before the
trouble they had in 1987. combining the
two of them because you have pat
robertson running
what
is going to be different in 1988 because
of television than say
20 years ago
or even well eight years ago
uh
the
the
the problem uh is amplified
uh now
it's become more serious
um eight years ago it was serious enough
so that americans actually elected
a former
hollywood movie actor as president
um
what kind of marks do you give him he
was an actor do you are you
at this stage in the game what would you
how would you rate the current
president's
well you mean the current candidates no
no the current president president
ronald reagan what marks do you give him
well i would
uh
uh of course i i didn't vote for him and
and and wouldn't and uh
i don't want my um
you know my own political uh preferences
to get in the way of this point because
if the democrats
could have figured out i mean if they
could have run henry fonda
and and fonda would could have beaten
reagan i mean it it will come close they
would have done that just as well
so i uh
same time i don't want to avoid your
question
just generally i think the history of
the american presidency if you start
with you know washington and
go through reagan refutes darwin
all by itself
um but uh i i find reagan myself
appalling
that at this stage
um in
our history
that we would have
chosen someone
who was so ill-informed
um and so inarticulate
you blame that on television
television produces this
and and brian we may get gary hart
we may get gary hart
because
he is
an attractive
figure on television
and when he goes to work with television
you know armed with his head blower
and his youth
and a certain
sort of residual kind of
reminiscence of john f kennedy
which he works over pretty well
people may say that's what we want
because he gives off something
not that he gives but he gives off
something
that draws
i had an uncle just
who voted for reagan i mentioned this
because he was
all his life
a solid democrat
a man of about 80 years old at the time
and he voted for reagan and i asked him
why he voted for reagan this was in
reagan's competition against mondale and
this is what he said to me
he said because if i invite ronald
reagan
to my house and took him in the kitchen
and gave him a glass of tea and a
cracker
and told him my problems he would
understand
but if
i asked mondale to come in mondale
wouldn't know what the hell i'm talking
about
and i said well
where did you get this idea
and he said turn on the television
and look at them
so
no one is in quotes blaming television
television cree isn't
the fundamental point about television
is that it is not
a
medium
for the disdistribution
of
news
but it is a new conception of how to
represent politics
to people so so so it's a new
instrumentality
which has new conceptions of what a
debate is
new conceptions of what political
discourse is
new conceptions of what political
stature
reagan
is
i think kennedy
was our first television president
but
reagan is our first
great image president what what was what
is terrific about reagan
on television
is that when you look at reagan you can
project onto reagan
what you think a president should be
see kennedy was very much identifiable
as a bostonian
and carter very much
as a southerner
i think television in the long run works
against that strong identification which
i think is going to give cuomo a problem
dole would be very good except he gives
off
this tremendous sense of repressed
hostility
and he can't there's nothing he can do
about it
i mean the image his image guys are
going to work on it
but
this is going to be devastating to him
what he gives off is repressed hostility
and people turn away from that what
reagan gave off
was in a sense nothing
said reagan gives off
whatever you want
i am
and i think
some of the real savvy image managers
know this
better than i do
and they're going to work on that
see i mean if cuomo cuomo is too much
the ethnic
the new york
uh
you know italian
guy
street smart
what he gives i find very congenial i
mean my political position is what he
gives i like but we're not talking about
that and on television that's relatively
unimportant
by the way i mean just just one little
fact about this i think all through
president reagan's tenure as president
the polls more or less consistently
showed
that the majority of americans did not
agree
with most of his policies but they loved
him
so the old idea of politics do i agree
with this man or disagree with him
becomes
repressed the question now is do i like
him
or do i not like him
and so there's a new new kind of
politics now
and i'm sure as i said that most of the
uh image people who work with these guys
i mean
geraldine ferraro
uh
gave off something
over which you she has no control
just as i have no control over what i'm
giving off now
and um
uh
by the way you have any idea what you're
giving off
well i mean you know yourself i mean you
what do you think
what's the worst thing somebody's out
there saying about you right now
well some people are probably saying
um
this guy claims to know more than he
really does
uh probably because when you get in
front of television you know you're apt
to
uh talk when the guy asks you questions
wouldn't it be great
if i could say to some of your questions
you know let's think about this brian
then the two of us would just sit there
here's the problem the problem is
thinking is not a performing art
and television requires a performing art
so we almost never see anyone thinking
by the way every once in a while when i
watch the buckley show what is it the
open no
firing line or dick hefner show the open
mind you will see people actually
thinking
which is why they're never on them prime
time
but most of the time you can't see
people thinking because you have to do
something
perform
now i'm not really quite sure what i
give off i did do the sunrise semester
for cbs you know that nyu did many years
ago it actually was
not that i was on it but all that time
but it was one of the longest running
network
programs in the history of television i
think only captain kangaroo and lucy or
ed sullivan were longer
and so i used to give these lectures
and then i would get letters from people
uh it's all and all the letters were
about what i gave off
except i got about 1500 letters in um
a period of four months
of fewer than 50 had anything to do with
the content of my remarks
they were all about what i gave off
and i did get letters from people who
would tell me things
that they wouldn't uh tell others you
know i'd get a letter i remember one in
particular dear dr postman i'm a 72 year
old widow
in an old person's home in pittsburgh
my sainted husband
died six years ago but don't worry about
it dr postman he left me well fixed my
daughter lives in montreal my son lives
in los angeles
i wish them the best but you would think
dr postman
that they send me a card
or call me on my birthday well that's
the way life is sometimes you know it
would go on and
so
this is was wondrous you know why is
this woman telling me this thing
so i thought well maybe i was look she
what i gave off was
that i'm sort of her son
or i'm a confidant but other people
i gave off different things
i haven't been on television enough
to know
we'll find out we're about we're out of
time but we're going to find out what
you give up i want to ask you
you have any other book
in the works about television follow on
to this book only uh the one before it
which was called the disappearance of
childhood was also about television and
its impact on the children but the one
coming out which will be in out this
year in the september
is a series of essays
on technology language and education and
some of those
are about television
dr neil postman author of amusing
ourselves to death public discourse in
the age of show business thank you very
much for joining us thank you
you